put simply peak performance is a
checklist and what i always tell people
is at the end of every day i make up a
checklist for what i'm doing the next
day
when i put it on the checklist i'm
making a promise to myself that i'm
doing this tomorrow
do you think that many of the things
that we do and enjoy in life
are just subtle delivery mechanisms for
flow
yes um and i'm not the only one uh
so uh can i define flow for your
listeners first before we do this
cool um flow is uh flow is
obviously at the heart of the work i do
and it's and it's what
predominantly we studied the flow
research collective or at the
neurobiology of low so
where does the state come from in our
brain flow is technically defined though
this is a very useful definition as an
optimal state of consciousness where we
feel our best and we perform our best
it is more specifically any of those
moments of rapt attention total
absorption gets so focused on the task
at hand so focused on what you're doing
everything else just seems to disappear
action awareness are going to start to
merge when that happens sense of self
self-consciousness going to get quiet
it's going to diminish time's going to
pass strangely it'll slow down you're
going to freeze program with that
occasionally um more frequently speeds
up
five hours go by in like five minutes
throughout all aspects of performance
mental and physical go through the roof
now
flow has a bunch of core psychological
characteristics when psychologists
measure the state they say hey it's got
these six core characteristics i named a
bunch of them
but the one you're asking about is the
last one which is the state is
autotelic which is a fancy greek word
that means an
end in itself and what this means is
well neurobiologically in really plain
english
flow is the best we get to feel on the
planet it's the most addictive state on
earth and we will go extraordinary far
out of our way to get more of it
and me high chick sent me high abraham
maslow
william james myself a lot of people
have made the argument that
hey pretty much everything we call
meaning and purpose
and happiness and joy that we're talking
about flow
except me i has argued that almost
everything we think of as
art is a flow delivery mechanism for the
user
uh saleem ismail uh former head of uh
president of singularity university
where they study exponential technology
and this application to kind of
global challenges an old friend of mine
an innovation expert used to uh be the
head of innovation at yahoo
he once pointed out and i wrote about
this in residency meant
or stealing fire he said you know when
you think about it
when you pay money to go to a sporting
event you're actually paying money to
see people in flow
in fact if you go to the movies you're
watching actors in flow
poetry reading it's poetry flow you go
to a restaurant you want the chef and
flow you want the waiter and flip
if you quantify it i'll bet it's a large
portion of gdp and then we
quantified it in stealing fire and we
quantified what we called the altered
state of
economy how much money do people
actually spend to alter their
consciousness
into these positive feel-good states
flow among others
and it turns out to like we spend 1 16th
of the global economy
chasing altered states of consciousness
so yes
not only like do i think it's real a lot
of smart people have thought it's real
and if you're
simply going by economic numbers and by
the way we may
you can look at the uh footnote and
stealing fire there's like a five-page
footnote on how we did the calculation
it was the most concern we're probably
wrong by a factor of 10 because we were
so conservative i'll give you an example
you can make the argument that any time
you go to see live music
you're going to have a flow experience i
want communitas i want to merge with the
band and be one with the audience
but okay we said so people maybe they go
to grock concerts or other concerts for
all these other reasons but edm
there's no lyrics you're not going for
the lyrics the clubs are disgusting most
of the time you're not going to the big
clubs
you're just going to dance and the music
like that's
it so we took edm instead of the whole
of the concert industry we just took edm
and we're still like 1 16th in the
global economy so you know
i'm super conservative and probably
wrong so yes is the asking your question
resoundingly
i love it i you won't know but i run
club nights so for the last
15 years i've run some of the uk's
biggest club night so i've watched this
collective effervescence
unfold in front of me right i've seen
the the
dance moves completely done in
coordination with people that aren't
even in your group without having spoken
to them
all that sort of stuff completely lost
in the moment so
yeah i am i totally see that why
does flow exist in the repertoire of
human
states like why is it adaptive so
it's a great question there's a bunch of
different answers
i'll give you three and i'll try to be
quick answer one
uh runner's high is a version of flow
right
and in runner's high you get
uh kind of spaced out while running and
you get a lot of pain relief anandamide
and uh endorphins both show up they're
powerful painkillers so here's the idea
we're the only species that evolve to
run down our prey we can outrun distance
wise any species on earth
so any human being back when who had a
little bit of pain relief
while running down their prey is going
to get more prey have more meat
healthier kids that's an evolutionary
driver over time
that goes forward so that's theory one
um a lot of people
pretty much think that's where it came
from in the first place
where it's problematic is flow shows up
in all mammals it's not just humans it's
common found can be found in most
mammals dogs can get into flow horse
skin flow this horse
rider flow when you have riders and
jockeys and dog trainer flow and like
all that stuff happens too
um in fact my first conversation with
mihai chick sent me high the godfather
flow psychology was
my wife and i run an animal sanctuary
and i was like email them i was like
look i think i'm getting in the flow of
my dogs is that [ __ ] even possible
right like that was my first
conversation with him years and years
ago
because i was like this is crazy could
this possibly be really he's like no no
check this out
um so the work i did that i wrote about
in a small furry prayer
um sort of put forth a different idea
that a bunch of us sort of think might
be true so humans and dogs co-evolved
about 40 000 years ago we teamed up with
wolves and
this was tremendous from an evolutionary
perspective
wolves were like first of all they they
ate our leftovers so our camps were
clean they were our garbage disposals
they barked danger they were our
security
alarms um they babysat our kids we'd go
off hunting and the wolves would be
right on it they were
where's the term three dog night come
from it's a night so damn cold you need
three dogs or
wolves in the bed with you to stay right
so we cohabitated with wolves
we hunted with wolves we hunted big prey
back in an arrow if you got a scratch
you could lose your arm and die
right like you can't screw up when
you're hunting buffalo
and there's no hospital or medicine or
antibiotics or anything like that
so i don't know if you've ever run with
a large pack of dogs i do that because
it's part of the work i do with the
animals if you
google stephen cutler a five dog workout
you can see what
the work we do with dogs um and how it
involves a lot of running with a pack of
dogs
outside television sent a crew to my
house years ago to document it it's
funny you'll laugh it
it's about how gen how do you generate
flow in animals because flow boosts the
immune
system and we do hospice care and
special needs care so uh you can boost
the immune system into a bunch of
good stuff in animals by getting them
into flow it's not hard dogs are so hard
wired for it anyways
but if you go out running with dogs you
freaking trip all over each other i mean
they're they're spazzes and like it's
dangerous and if you were running down
prey
and you had other dudes running with you
and they had spears it'd be a freaking
mess
but inflow one of the things that
happens is massively hiding pattern
recognition
right and so with group dynamics team
four to what you were talking about the
clubs where everybody's dancing the same
moves how does that happen
it happens because inflow all the
brain's information processing systems
are
checked up more information per second
we fast process it faster find faster
connections between
incoming information and older ideas and
then we act on it faster and faster
twitch muscle response because amplifies
literally we act on it faster so all
that stuff gets way jacked up and when
dogs and humans snap in to flow together
suddenly everyone's in formation right
that's why we do a lot of flow work with
the u.s special forces the navy seals
even like the national guard
whatever they all want the teams in flow
because everybody has to
not seals they move non-hierarchically
they're going to storm a building and
get back a kidnap victim
the guy who knows what to do next gets
to be the leader that's how they do it
and there's no time to
talk or it's all nonverbal coordination
all through heightened pattern
recognition all done through flow
so that seems like it got
into the lineage through painkiller
but because part of it is you get
dopamine and flow and this amplifies
pattern recognition
it seems like when we teamed up with
wolves it was
better cooperation intra-species
cooperation
and cross-species flow and this is a
huge driver
so the same thing little more prey when
you were getting into flow and getting
painkiller but if you're suddenly
getting performance enhancing chemicals
and
team dynamics and everything else way
more prey
much safer and so that's the next thing
and there's a current theory and again
these are
these are not mutually exclusive this is
a theory that i just written i think
it's freaking brilliant so
to get into flow what you have to do is
it flows what happens when you learn a
bunch of different individual skills and
they come together so you're trying to
like
swing a baseball bat or a cricket bat
right in the beginning it's like
keep your eye on the ball and swing with
your arms straight and step into the and
it's like 17
different moves and then boom it comes
together and then booms comes together
and it
slows down and suddenly you can twist
your wrist a little and put spin on the
ball to send it to right field or left
field or blah blah blah i'm giving you
baseball analogies which is probably
useless in britain but whatever
um you get my point and i talk really
fast so i apologize
um but um
that uh when we automatize a series of
movements
and they we can now do them as one
unique movement
without conscious intervention without
the the new theory is hey if that
happened it'd be really good
from a uh a brain perspective if we
had a signal if the body gave us a
signal that
hey this thing you've been trying to
learn you've suddenly you've got it
unlocked you can now do it no matter
what um zen flow is your signal so
these are not mutually exclusive things
and one may have led to the other and
that led to the other um so it's
hard to tell that's the current thinking
and let's
say that there's a fourth one which is
maybe i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about
all this could be wrong in two weeks
from now somebody will figure it out
right so there's i sound very erratic
but they're caveat this is evolutionary
theory
and nobody the sciences can only take us
so far
what i think is so interesting there is
the interspecies stuff the fact that you
can get yourself
into a mode that allows everything not
just
everybody but everything including the
creatures that you're with
to continue to go and it's cool to think
that um
the sensation of flow is almost like a
mastery alert
like a little mastery indicator right
that's exactly that's exact that's all
that's up i'm stealing that
that's perfect that's the easiest way to
describe it but yeah that's essentially
um that was a theory i want to say i
want to give credit where creditors do i
think it's peter ulum who came up with
it i could
or or demonzano um there
one is at olm university in germany the
other is at the carol institute
institute
uh in sweden and they're brilliant flow
researchers um
and uh i think that argument is made
actually
in this book effortless attention which
is a
book on of one of the textbooks on flow
actually
what's the difference seven or eight
textbooks i bet you do what's the
difference between
peak performance and flow is it the same
thing
yeah so this is interesting first of all
it depends who you ask
right it really depends who you ask
i tend to think of peak performance
as nothing more or less than well first
of all people performance is just
performing your best in
whatever situation you're interested in
but it is
people i define people performance as
getting your biology to work for you
rather than against you right and that
biology
is a limited set of skills there are a
bunch of motivational skills
then there are a bunch of learning
skills there are a bunch of creativity
skills and there are a bunch of flow
skills
right and those are catch-all terms when
psychologists say motivation they don't
just mean energy for action they mean
extrinsic motivation the stuff in the
world will work hard to get
money sex fame intrinsic motivation
passion
purpose autonomy they mean goals and
grit so these are catch-all terms
the way to think about that that sweet
that's sort of it's almost a mnemonic in
my mind but
in any situation motivation gets you
into the game
learning allows you to continue to play
creativity
is how you steer right create a problem
solving greater decisions how you steer
and then flow is how because it's
optimal performance how you amplify
the results of those efforts usually
beyond all reasonable expectation
because that's just what flow does
right if you look at the the skills that
flow amplifies
now um it's motivation grit productivity
learning
creativity cooperation collaboration
right to
uh empathy and environmental awareness
and you've got to ask yourself
here's the other final answer to your
question
why all these skills why would one state
of consciousness optimize environmental
awareness your ability to see and
perceive the natural world
empathy learning rates and grit i mean
like what are you ta
and and fast twitch muscle response
right and increase strength 15
like what are you talking about why and
the answer is
really simply we gave we talked about a
bunch of evolutionary stuff but here's
the high level view
evolution drove our biology scarcity
drives evolution scarcity resources
is the biggest driver of evolution
there's only two responses to scarcity
you can fight over dwindling resources
or
you can get creative get cooperative get
innovative
and make new resources so why does flow
optimize all this
crap because these are the two that it
optimizes everything you need to either
fight
flee or get innovative get creative get
cooperative and make new resources so
where it came from there why did it
stick around
big picture before we start to talk
about the components of
peak performance is there anything that
people need to understand first
is that like a a primer for the primer
i don't there really isn't the only
um there really isn't the one thing
that that i want to say here and i don't
know if this is true across the board
more research needs to be done but we
have found
that if you're into i mean there are
some basics and some stuff that like you
know
but all that's covered are impossible
and this is talked about a little bit
are impossible
but so there's something called a locus
of control you have an internal locus of
control which means
i feel like i am in charge of my life i
can control my destiny i can draw my
life i can control what happens to me
or you have an external locus of control
i'm a victim life happens to me i've got
no control here
and um sometimes this gets talked about
as a growth mindset versus a
fixed mindset they're roughly the same
terms but
neurobiologically there's a little
difference either way
if you don't have an internal locus of
control if you think life happens to you
if you're a victim
if you feel like you're a victim um
it basically shuts off the brain's
ability to participate in the world
basically says the brain because the
brain is a high
energy organism that always wants to
conserve energy 25
of your energy is being used by the
brain at rest it's two percent of your
body mass
first order business for the brain is
always conserve energy conserve energy
so if you think life happens to you and
you've got
no control in a given situation when a
problem arises or things like that your
brain sometimes won't even exert the
energy to try
because why bother if you have no
control here and are going to lose
anyways
right we'll save the energy to deal with
the fallout later
so how deep this goes
how much it paralyzes any pursuit
performance remains an open
question but that's the only thing i can
think of
that um right that's that's the one
where i think
we don't have a good answer here it's
like
but considering especially in america
today because in
there's such a huge social justice
movement thank god phenomenal
but it produces a lot of victim mindset
right there's a lot of that and i'm not
saying that the social justice causes
aren't
righteous and true in the art like
everything everybody's saying is
right but from a peak performance
standpoint from performance standpoint
if you you're a victim you think life
happens to you
um you're kind of screwed and so that's
that's you know what i mean that's just
the biology and
um which is funny because it's the
biology that sort of
like led some of the social justice
argument right some of the argument
going on
is being biologically led but the you
know the argument itself is causing more
problems
it's interesting i don't know what the
solution is that is so certain
yeah that's so circular what you've just
gone through there
i think is what being introduced to your
work
has been so interesting for me
personally
because what you do your understanding
of applied neuroscience and the biology
but also the psychology and the
phenomenological experience of what's
going on
it's not just about a victim mentality
is a word that everybody's heard before
but how does that manifest like what
does it mean
and the places that you've gone with
your research and why i find it
more compelling so much more compelling
than most of the stuff that i've read
with regards to peak performance
is that it's a lot more tacit
and explicit and and it feels like the
substance behind it
because there's a lot of even in
psychology
oh there's just nonsense it's like
armchair philosophizing right about
here's the thing everybody understands
their own experience of when they feel
good and when they feel bad
and they could say well do you know what
it is before i before i give a talk i
always go for a walk and i do that
but you actually understand the stuff
that you've done and the work that
you've done breaks that down and looks
okay so what's happening when you walk
what's happening when your eyes are
exposed to light and when you're
moving and you're going through
locomotion whilst thinking and all this
sort of stuff
so yeah that breakdown there that you've
just said i think really
perfectly identifies why this is so
important and different as well
so um at the flow research collective
right through the organization we study
the neurobiology of peak performance
we have a a hardcore philosophy that we
sort of live by which is
personality doesn't scale biology scales
and because what you see is in coaching
it's exactly what you just said in
self-help and coaching
um you see people who figure out what
works for them
and then they teach to other people and
usually it fails sometimes it's a total
disaster
and the reason is really simple
personality what works for you what
works for me
my personality was created by my
genetics and my early childhood
experience
and really foundational stuff that
really matters
how you're going to approach people
performance like where are you on the
introversion extroversion scale
what are your risk tolerances these are
mostly genetically coded or locked into
place by other childhood experience
you can change some of them but it's
often very slowly over long periods of
time if you go one level down to the
neurobiological mechanism that we all
share
well that scales the problem with
psychology has been
as useful as it is it's metaphor
psychology's metaphor
and neurobiology is mechanism you want
it reliable and repeatable you want
neurobiology and your
flow is the perfect example if you go
back into the 90s and you can read this
go read like me how chicks have behind
susan jackson
godfather psychology and the first
woman to really try to apply it to sport
they wrote a book together called flow
and sport and they tried to teach
leading athletes using the psychology
how to use flow
and it's not very successful their hit
rate is pretty
lousy right and these were literally the
two
two of the brightest people the entire
world and it's not their fault
it's the psychology is squishy like it
does like what when you say my partner
who i write books sometimes peter
diamandis when he says mindset he means
attitude
towards life when carol dweck gets
stamford's mindset
she means attitude towards learning and
what she actually means is
no no if you have the right attitude
toward learning this part of your brain
that allows you to learn
turns the [ __ ] on and this part turns
off
that so like why do you what's the who
cares about the language what you want
is this part of your brain
on and this part of your brain off and
that's what matters
so let's start there and work you know
work work our way
up rather than the other way around
because it's the other way around it's
just too squishy and it's too subjective
and
you know and you can make a mess of
things real especially you know
if your risk tolerances my risk
tolerances are off the chart i mean like
my retirements are ridiculous um and i
run around professional action support
athletes and you know
that's what i that's who i research and
hang out with and that's what i do in my
free time
and i've got insane risk tolerances and
broken 82 bones
so do you want me to do you want you
want to know what works for me
you know how i get into flow i go skiing
the trees at 40 miles an hour
often alone listen to the wu-tang clan
at full volume
that's what i do i mean like seriously
like
we're gonna train other people oh yeah
we i mean we train a thousand people
about at the flow research collective
right we the c-suite of accenture
right now is being trained by us how
many of them do you think are going to
want to ski through the trees at 40
miles an hour listen to the wu tag lab
that would be the best you get my point
that would be the best introduction you
know the first the first
uh the flow collective weekend away
right come on guys we're going to jump
on the skis it's just going to get you
into this right state and then
yeah dirty pair of pants and a couple of
broken bones later
so going into the the components you
break peak performance down you said it
before
motivation learning creativity and flow
and so did nietzsche
apparently why those sections and how do
they fit together in that order
everybody everybody the point is this
peak performance is nothing more or less
than getting our biology to work for us
rather than against us as i said it's a
limited set of biology
if you're so if you're a peak performer
i'd say this all the time if you read
the art of impossible and you're
let's say your top 30 percent of
whatever it is you're doing that could
be stamp collected right i don't care
um huge chunks of the book
sixty percent um i would say are going
to be
familiar they're gonna be stuff you're
probably
doing right you may not know what order
you're doing it in or you may go oh i'm
doing this i didn't know i should be
doing this as part of it but oh cool i
get that
oh i should do this too oh i'm doing
this i'm doing this i'm doing this i
didn't know about this right
that's everybody's experience right who
who's good at their job
and is reading this book oh i'm doing
some of this i didn't know it was a
system i didn't know it was designed to
work in order
it's because it's a limited it's just
the biology right we're all going in the
same direction
we've been doing this really cool
project i'm trying to open sources so we
can make it huge but there's been this
huge outpouring of peak performance uh
experts who now all have podcasts
including it turns out me um and uh
you can uh we want to do an open source
project where we like have
listeners listen to podcasts and say
okay this is the podcast they talked
about grit and this was the advice and
this was the advice and make a giant
matrix about it so we could
get all right like there's brilliant
minds who are talking about this stuff
all the time and lots of people are
interested in so like this kind of crowd
storage
project to figure out where there's
overlap and where's the crazy or where
there's a possible new idea that
nobody's seen before that's worth
examining
this would be really useful but we
started doing that at a lower level the
flow research collective a bunch of
years ago
and i started doing it on my own just
every time i listened to a podcast i
would just like fill out a little grid
thing
and it didn't take like we're all it's
the same stuff
the only advantage i had in this
particular
universe some a lot of these experts
like there are great books on
focus or mindfulness or gratitude or you
know written by
amazing experts and you know i'm lucky
enough the flow research collected that
a lot of these people who have written
the books
and are the experts they work with me at
the collective so like
you know that's we're a collective of
you know we try to be the
best in the world um in this stuff so
that's that's that was the goal when i
started
we aim for that maybe we failed but
that's what we're trying for
so but there's lots of experts in lots
of these subjects
i because flow is the big picture and if
you're going to be an expert on flow
well you better know i mean if flow
optimizes
empathy and environmental awareness and
motivation and like i better know what
the hell i'm talking about on
all those subjects and when i started
research and because i'm a neuro guy
when i started reading about the neuro
how do all these things work what's
going on in the brain what parts of the
brain are getting at
you start seeing oh wait a minute this
is all one thing this is all one system
and other people have started putting
this together
um dt and ryan are the two big
brains in motivation that you kind of
did some a lot of the early work on
intrinsic motivation
ryan went on to write a lot of really
cool stuff on intrinsic motivation and
neurobiology when it went from
psychology into neurobiology
he wrote a bunch of papers where you can
start to see the kernels of the bigger
picture starting to emerge a little bit
but um i don't think he was looking at
creativity um but because i was you know
i run a course called flow for writers
where i
you know it's all the stuff applied to
creativity and art and
whatever i was really i've been for a
long time looking at creativity
how does this stuff apply to creativity
and that was a totally different field
it's a totally different world it gave
me
you know and the learning stuff matters
because we train a thousand people a
month and you can't
like you can't drain that many people
and be bad at it right like they don't
let you
they get mad i've discovered
yeah i bet that they do it's um
i think i know that you're a fan of
david epstein as well he's
yeah great past guest on the show and
learning about
the advantage that a generalist has
especially coming out of the
the henry ford era the scientific
management the specialized the workforce
you know think about what the subtext
was that we're being told culturally
there you know narrow and deep narrow
and deep
um it's interesting
yeah david's work on range um
in where he talks about range is
brilliant and it's you know
it's a it's not just an argument for
generalism it's an argument
for generalism as a path towards what
you know what economists talk about is
match fit which is a
perfect match it's ad i think adam grant
actually coined the term or he's the one
where david got it that's where i think
it came from
um but match fit is a match between your
strengths
your values and the work you do in the
world and if you can
get match fit things hyper accelerate
right
basically in the book of the beginning
of art impossible i talk about how do
you line up all your intrinsic
motivators how do you get curiosity
passion purpose autonomy mastery the big
five entrance of motivators
all pointed in the same direction right
by the end of the
stack you also have to start adding in
your strengths and your values
but if you get all that stuff pointing
the same direction
it's rocket fuel right it's just
everything goes
so much faster and i think match
fit is the like quiet economic term
for the same thing but that's that's the
the point
he's making is generalism in search of
match fit
gives you the best long-term results if
you're interested in walking about the
mastery i will also say
i'm gen x and i don't know
i don't know if this is very true for my
generation i don't know if it was true
for the generations that came before me
and i'm not quite sure it's
still true today but we
really wanted to be renaissance men and
women
like i grew up not just wanting to go
deep i was
like you had to be great you had to be a
good athlete you'd be a great athlete
you had to be a great
artist you had to be a great kind of
intellectual you wanted to succeed in
the business like you wanted to kill it
everywhere
and that was like we would how do you do
that how do you know what i mean it
wasn't like
generalism was really weird and i was an
old school punk rocker
and you know it's a diy movement so we
were like
renaissance men and women who were going
to do it ourselves we were like okay
we're going gonna figure
all of it like neuroscience cools uh
where do i start reading you know what i
mean tennis cool give me a racket let's
go
what do you think most people have wrong
about motivation
uh i think there's two answers here the
first is that um
and i think they're related the first is
that
people really mystify especially in
today's culture we mystify passion and
purpose
oh it's purpose it's very altruistic and
let me
lead with my purpose hi i'm wendy
and i'd like to save the trees in nepal
right i mean like wendy honestly if you
were saving the trees in nepal you
wouldn't have to talk to me about it i
would already know and that's why i'd be
talking to you in the first place if you
have to tell me
you're disqualifying yourself as
somebody who's actually saving the trees
to paul
so you're telling me you're taking up
space and like what
but all that aside um did i just say
that out loud
okay anyways that's uh it happens so
passion and purpose matter on a really
simple level
because focus is the most expensive
thing we spend our energy on
period it's the mo when and if you look
at any situation
any performance situation i don't care
what it is you're doing you want to be a
little bit better at work next monday or
you want to go
right after world records um first of
all the biology is the same
and you don't have a lot of levers what
do you in any situation
bowling you've got your focus that
you're going to bring to the
bowling and you've got that bowling
skills now
you can get more bowling skills that's
called practice
it takes a very long time and it goes
slowly and it goes slowly for all of us
and the rules are the same crawl walk
run right you're gonna
suck until you don't suck and it's slow
so focus is the big lever
as i said earlier your brain 25 of your
energy at rest forgetting you're not
even paying attention
at rest daydreaming mode um and uh
about two percent of your mass so big
energy hog always looking for
kind of ways to conserve or even better
ways to get something for free when we
are curious about something when we are
passionate about something when we are
purposeful about something we get
focused
for free that's the huge deal we don't
have to work so damn hard to pay
attention to something
and we're not burning all that energy
focus for free that's why passion
matters that's why purpose matters
purpose matters more than passion
because passion that focus for free
comes in the form of norepinephrine and
dopamine these are feel good reward
chemicals
that do double duty as focusing
chemicals also
right what happens when you go from
passion to purpose
meaning i take my passion the thing that
i'm most passionate about and i couple
it to a cause greater than myself
so my passion is flow science and
research
but now i'm going to do flow science and
research and make the world a better
place with my flow science and research
the reason i want to do that it may be
that i want to help the world in kumbaya
but from a peak performance perspective
i want endorphins oxytocin
and serotonin which are proso social
feel good reward chemicals and they're
super motivators so they're like we may
the first thing people get wrong is we
make we mystify passion and purpose i
think it's
all these things it's not it's a
focusing
uh it's about focus and reward
neurochemistry
that drives performance that's what
we're talking about
so it's i think it's helpful to just
like bring it back down to the ground
like this is the other thing that people
really get wrong
and i think this is the big one is just
because you
have passion and purpose it's not gonna
feel good like it's a like
it doesn't mean it's easy and it doesn't
mean it feels good in fact one of the
hardest things most peak performers
discover
so there comes a point every every
everybody's life where the thing you're
most passionate about becomes your
prison
right like that writers can get trapped
i you know i've written a couple of
books that were really tough
and it's like a two-year hell that
you're living inside of
you know what i mean so it's like it
doesn't mean that i wasn't passionate
about the book
it just meant that it was damn hard and
you know
i had to i had to bang my head into
walls a lot um
how did you drag yourself out of that
how do people get out of those rooms
i just uh you for me i just do the work
and finish the project
i mean like you know what i'm in like i
don't all my
like i don't mind if it's hard i like i
you know what i mean i i
i ask this question to people all the
time um
which is uh tell me the things in your
life
that you're proudest of and that made
the biggest difference and led to like
the biggest
change and like improvement in your
performance afterwards
right so nobody tells me about the time
they got lucky
right they tell me oh i worked for five
years seven
jobs just to get through college but i
finally got this degree and
like that's what you hear about
stuart brand once said and i think he's
he's not wrong that the only sustainable
happiness is the satisfaction of a job
well done
and he's not actually wrong when it
comes to happiness there are three
levels of of
sort of happiness and well-being that
are available humans the first level is
moment by moment and happiness um how do
you feel right here right now which is
what stewart was talking about
and he's probably right there the next
level's up enjoyment and then um
meaning and purpose all involved flow so
enjoyment is a high flow lifestyle and
meaning a purpose is a high flow
lifestyle where the thing generating
flow is attached to something meaningful
in the world
and that's the best we get to feel like
if you want to find people who score off
the charts for overall life satisfaction
while being the people with the most
flow in their lives
and usually that flow is coming from
something it's tied up something
greater than themselves the interesting
thing from that
is being selfless is oddly the most
selfish thing that you can do
by serving other people you serve
yourself
so here's the funny thing and there's a
there's an inversion of that which is
also true which is equally weird
so flow and a bunch of other altered
states experiences including psychedelic
experiences
the ego the self disappears but on the
back
end of these experiences right the ego
comes like
roaring back i mean have you ever met
more
blowhards than are like existing in the
psychedelic community right now
like how many people morons with a
philosophy about
you know take mushrooms find god beat
drums have lots of sack
like really okay cool i was in high
school too i didn't know that was a
philosophy
let's go yeah so being selfless
is one of the most selfish things you
can do but also destroys the self and
then can cause it to come back
greater than it ever was before which
you know we have a t
we don't have so much swag at the floor
research collectively we have a t-shirt
that says never trust the dopamine
because the big ego high comes with a
dopamine and you want the dub
mean for focus for energy or drive
but if you start actually believing what
it's
telling you the message it's telling you
oh my god you'll make all kinds of
disastrous decisions i'll give you a
we tell people also like the flow master
behind the pattern recognition we talked
about that so like
common sense don't go shopping on a flow
state you will buy everything
you'll be like uh you'll have a great
idea to single-handedly reinvent
70s polyester disco fashion ha ha
staying alive
right i mean you're going to come home
and you're going to be like i bought
what
how about what you're gonna be disgusted
with yourself
honey i i i i've asked out the visa
you'll never believe why oh my god
yeah that's so interesting i've never
thought that flo actually could be a
being in a flow state could be
misappropriated into a
an imperfect environment and put you on
the back foot we write about it as
fire um but like so couple things about
flow
lot of stuff is amplified but you just
watched as the prefrontal cortex from
the brain are shut down
prepare to cortex handles logical
complex decision-making
long-term planning does some risk
assessment
so i tell people that like if anybody
like there's a cult leaders put people
in the flow
if somebody like puts drop helps you get
into flow and then tries to make meaning
for you
run the other way you're in a cult like
get that's like you you gotta this is
this is your powerful
technologies there's a whole bunch of
people in the self-help world
who put people into flow using various
techniques
you know um and then upsell them hey
do you feel how good that is check out
my new
platinum level superstar turbo program
right risk assessment is off long term
planning
is shut down that like there's an
argument that that should be a little
illegal right like there there is an
argument for that um uh but
the my my point is like flow is a tool
right it's ethically neutral be used for
good
it can be used for ill in fact you go
back to the 1950s and you you can take
your pick on if this is good or ill but
the 50s flow literature is all about
combat flow
it's about soldiers in world war ii and
group flow situations and
you know things like that so um you know
i always say that a cat burglar when
they're stealing your jewels they're
definitely in flow
that's a good point you know you start
the creativity section off with a quote
from salvador dali that says
i don't do drugs i am drugs
what does that mean to you
i love that quote i've thought a lot
about that quote um
i think what dolly was getting at
was that he was trying to describe
reality from a phenomenological
perspective reality as we actually
experienced it right
he was talking about elongated time so
his
clocks were stretched time elongates in
flow
so like a lot of the stuff that he was
trying to get at the phenomenology
i think is in and around altered states
of consciousness
i think what uh what dollywood
meant is that experiencing his art
was transformative in that way
and there's something interesting about
that because you know the
empathy is the study of empathy as a
psychological as a scientific topic is
that is this is this question where
we the origins of empathy science was
art
how is it that you look at a painting
and suddenly you
feel the thing the artist was feeling
when they painted the painting how the
hell does that work
right it's an emotion transported
through an object into another person
okay yeah and how'd that work exactly
like what are we talking about here
that was that was where early research
into empathy came from they were trying
to
figure out how does that possibly work
and dolly
can't that was work that was really
getting a lot of attention in the late
1870s 80s and 90s
so i'm guessing dolly at least
encountered it
um i don't know his exact dates but i'm
guessing he bumped up against
i mean 1920s he was painting heavily
maybe tens
i'm guessing like he's in art school in
the 1890s
or early you know and they're talking
about this stuff i'm guessing i could
you know what i mean i could be wrong
that's what i that's my
semi-area guess or i'm possibly stephen
talking out of his butthole
perhaps yeah i am i did so much research
for a recent talk i gave
and i used dali as one of the examples
so i did a full deep dive on the guy
i cannot believe how eccentric he was i
absolutely cannot believe the depths of
his eccentricity i
haven't been well that whole group of
people it's interesting to me
um first of all i always point out that
like europeans
are very quiet and stayed and generally
uptight
until they decide not to be and then get
the hell out of the way just get out of
the way yeah everything's and
everything's up for sale
everything's fair game everything like
you take really repressed cultures with
long cultural histories that are really
like set in stone
and then you know we we have i think of
it
so in science there's this really weird
things that happens
where if you have a scientist who
happens a lot you see in physics more
than anything else
they suddenly they discover they start
they get interested in something that
scientists said is not possible and they
you know start poking at in it suddenly
possible and this can be
flow science or things like that but
something like it opens
like once they believe in one thing that
might be a little bit controversial
suddenly everything's fair game and the
entire like all the critical thinking
that they brought to every step of their
career
seems to go out the window at it that
minute
like 10 minutes ago you were a really
smart
smart biologist and suddenly we're
talking about something
yeah exactly like what the hell happened
like and can i smoke some too
that's what we need yeah it's um did you
know that
i'm gonna guess that you will have done
did you know that dali was named
salvador because his
younger brother died nine months before
he was born and his parents believed
that he was the reincarnation of his
dead brother
so that's not too much weight to bear i
mean you know that's not
unfair expectations for a child it's
okay
do you know what he did with him now
let me tell you about your brother
you're dead that you are your name
the one that you are yeah exactly what
you are by the way this is
so you got dolly in the dalai lama i got
it
if you're named ollie you're the real
there you go
that's it the um the other one the best
thing that i heard so he married
he left his first marriage for another
one that he was having an affair this
lady was having an affair with
and he referred to her as his muse he
said that this is the woman who is
supplying me with all of my artistic
inspiration
and upon getting married he bought her a
castle immediately started treating her
like monarchy like immediately did
and then didn't move into the castle
he'd purchased her
he sent her formal requests by letter
to be able to see her in the castle that
he'd bought her
and she had to respond so he was
treating her like some sort of
sacred royal this heritage this
completely like unprofane
area and um yeah he he literally treated
like a goddess
incarnate
what a guy
i know it's jaw dropping man i don't
know what to do with that that's amazing
wow um
so maybe he meant something different by
i am drugs then like
uh maybe he was going much farther than
yeah you think that you know darli
darlies dally's beyond our me and mortal
comprehension i think
yeah more researchers needed stephen
exactly right we've now got the dali
research collective um which is
going to be a sub discipline so go back
going back to creativity going back to
the darley thing
how can people hack their creativity
so what's interesting um again this is
one of these cool things where you know
back in the 20th century
we were trying to use the psychology of
creativity to train creativity
and we weren't great at it the hit
record in the in 20th century was really
up and down
sometimes we were good sometimes we were
really bad and we couldn't figure out
why
and now we're starting to understand
first of all creativity is
less so much it's a skill it's also
a state of consciousness right there's
state changes in the brain when we're
creative
and we're now starting to understand the
neurobiology so like
simple things make a really big
difference i'll give you one
kind of like bit of neurobiological
information that that is often the
ballgame with creativity which is
anxiety so the more anxious you become
the more logical your brain gets
the more fear there is in the situation
the more your brain wants give me
something safe
something tried something true something
that works every time reliable or futile
extreme example if i'm acute anxiety
you get the fight-or-flight response
forget about options the buffet
is closed you can fight you can flee or
you can freeze i've given you three
choices right
that's an extreme situation but the same
thing happens
with any living levels of anxiety a
little bit is good
a little bit of focused attention it'll
get you curious
it'll it'll move you along but you know
uh too much and you have all kinds of
problems
the issue if we're gonna be a little
more formal is the
dorsal anterior cingulate cortex
which is a part of your brain does a
bunch of really interesting things one
of the things it does
is it finds remote associations between
ideas so when your brain creativity is
always your competitor your brain takes
a novel information and it finds
an older link to that new information
right
and uses the the new thing that comes
out of the two things being blended
together to create something startling
that's essentially creativity i'm at a
really basic level
but when you're scared the dorsal
anteriority of the cortex goes well dude
i don't want to
associate this thing that i do you know
this bit of novelty in the environment
with like what your grandmother said to
you back in sixth grade
because no this thing could be dangerous
and you're already stressed out because
of this thing at work and you're tired
you don't have a lot of energy so no no
no
being in a good mood really matters
because when you're in a good mood the
acc is calmer and it can find
farther flung connections between ideas
this is why if you're interested
in more creativity uh if you want to
train your nervous system
the best tools to reach for are either a
daily gratitude practice a daily
mindfulness focused meditation practice
or 20 to 40 minutes of
daily exercise those are the three best
ways
to flush stress hormones out of your
system so when we train people we're
like
you have to have some level of calmness
to do any peak performance
we say pick one do a five minute
gratitude practice or
a 11 minutes of focused meditation
focused breath work or 20-40 minutes of
exercise
if there's crisis stuff going on in the
world or
covid and people are stressed out do two
of these things a day
it'll keep your nervous system in check
enough
because flow is a high energy state we
all want to get into flow that's good
that's going to be the secret to
unlocking everything
but the calmer it's not the calmer you
are but the calm you're sort of starting
from as you're you're entering the thing
the better um and one of the big reasons
for flow
also for creativity um there's a bunch
of other way
other things like that but that's just a
simple example
um that's sort of what the new science
of creativity is about
how close is that window from doing
the action the daily habits is it
best for you to do the meditation or the
exercise
and then within six hours sit down to do
your work
oh um i don't um
that's an interesting question
i think it depends on where you are at
the time
for example um when i wake up and i'm
stressed out sometimes i'll like you
know i like to write first thing in the
morning that's when i work best and
focus best
but if i've come to work stressed out i
will do
a gratitude practice right i'll write
down 10 things i'm grateful for and
really try to feel each one of them
um if i'm not stressed out when i come
to work
and i don't get a chance to exercise
during the day i'll end my day with a
gratitude practice
just so i can make sure i've sort of
like reset my emotions before i go
like deal with my wife and talk to my
wife and like you know i don't want to
like spill my bad day all over her
that you know so i'll tune up my nervous
system that way
that kind of thing so i think it depends
on
sort of where you are how you are and
and what the situation is
i'm going to get i just for most people
um
some of the things that you've talked
about would probably be part of a
morning routine
most people also i think i think that's
true
i like to i literally like less than
seven minutes from the time i like roll
out of the bed to the time i'm like my
computer what do you do
i always wondered do you have a little
tune-up sequence before let's say it's a
normal day
stephen wakes up gets out of bed and
he's feeling just good out of 10 normal
out of the 10.
go to the bathroom make my bed walk from
my house to my office bring my dogs
along the way
put a cop pot of coffee on usually do my
gratitude practice while the
is brewing and then i then i write then
i start writing and i'm usually writing
within
five minutes i find that interesting
that you're
well the reason is this flow
among other flow is great for creativity
it's great for writing that's my goal
when i'm writing
flow takes place on the border line from
a brainwave perspective between alpha
and theta
so waking normal waking consciousness is
bait it's a fast-moving brain wave
alpha is daydreaming it's mode it's a
slower brainwave it's
more associated with high creativity um
and
then theta is rem sleep right it's it's
right there flow is the borderline
between alpha and theta it's a very it's
actually a calm from a brainwave
perspective a very calm state
this is this decreased activity in the
prefrontal cortex that we were talking
about
that's how it registers you wake up
in alpha you don't wake up you you will
jump
your brain will jump up to beta once it
starts racing but you wake up
mostly in alpha and unless you're you
know
having a bad dream or you know there's a
lot of other things that could happen is
general
you're waking up at alpha it's easier to
stay there
and you know drop down to the theta
borderline with flow
than it is to like get kicked into high
beta um
and so that's why i try to do it um
i think that's really interesting it's
cool to use something that you're going
to do every day as a
your pre-workout before work is
your sleep i think that's a good way a
good way to put it together
uh what are the things the
most common ways that you see people
knocking themselves out of flow
what are like the antithesis that people
get into on a daily basis
let me solve that for you a slightly
different way
if you go to www.flowblocker.com
we built the diagnostic there are six
major ways most people get knocked out
of flow
and uh distraction for example is a big
one there's a bunch of others anyways we
built a diagnostic
it's free for anybody and it will tell
you this is the thing that's standing
between you and the most flow
and give you a bunch of actionable steps
to solve that problem in your life
so that work we've done that work for
people
that's free um we we can jump to the
next one
i love that that's so that's awesome um
so let's talk about some flow triggers
then
so flow triggers are these sort of
proximal causes of flow itself and
they're split up into internal and
external
what are some of your favorites what do
you think people need to learn about if
they're new to this topic
yeah so uh flow states as you pointed
out they've got triggers these are
preconditions
that lead to more flow there are um
22 known flow triggers there are
probably way more but that's what we
know about
um there are 12 that fall into the
individual category what'll drive me
into flow or you into flow and then
there's
10 group flow triggers right what me and
you together in a flow state
interpersonal flow or a
brainstorming session group flow or you
know communitas flow at scale that's a
rock concert
that kind of thing but so there are 10
triggers for group flow they all work
the same way flow
follows focus it only shows up when all
of retention is in the right here right
now
so that's what the triggers do they
drive our attention into the present
moment they do it a bunch of different
ways they can either drive
dopamine or norap an effort into our
system we talked about those earlier
they're focusing chemicals the
performance against chemicals
sometimes the triggers will derive both
into your system sometimes it's just
one or the triggers will lower cognitive
load
cognitive load is all the crap you're
trying to think about any one time so by
lower cognitive load
i liberate some extra energy and you can
repurpose that for attention
so that's how the triggers work um
though the most important one
and the one i love the most i think
because it's
it's often called the golden rule flow
is what's known as the challenge skills
balance
this is the idea that this is by the way
the exact is a great follow-up to what
we were talking about because this is
another reason why anxiety blocks flow
so the challenge skills balance is
called the golden rule of flow
meaning flow follows focus we pay the
most attention to the task at hand
when the challenge of the task slightly
exceeds our skill set
you want to stretch but not snap now
stretch means you're outside your
comfort zone so if you have like
shy weak timid people um
this is a little difficult um for the
because you have to stretch beyond your
comfort zone so for flow hacking you got
to sort of get
comfortable being uncomfortable for like
uber top performers right when i'm
dealing with like c-suite executives or
wall street type a types the problem is
that they blow by this skill set because
they're used to taking on
giant challenges and and they it's not
you you should not that you shouldn't
take on the giant challenges that you
should chunk it down so the part you're
dealing with
that's right in front of you that's
right here right now that you're focused
on
sits in that that sweet spot so if i
were to say this
emotionally i'd say hey that's sweet
spot it's not on but it's pretty close
to near
the midpoint between anxiety too much
stimulation whoa
turn it off and boredom not enough
stimulation i can't pay any attention
in between is the sweet spot what is
psychologically referred to as the flow
channel or physiologically the herb
stops and curb
um either way
too much anxiety in your system right
for any other reason
and it's too much norepinephrine and it
turns up the challenge to go sweet spot
so it makes it
harder because you're already pushing
your skills to the utmost
and if you're super anxious as you know
it's really hard to push your skills to
the utmost i yeah i was skiing yesterday
i was thinking about this very
thing because um i spent a lot of time
skiing
and a lot of time trying to progress my
skiing and we were uh
in the terrain park yesterday working
pretty hard but we had skied
really hard man i mean the guy ski with
a lot the day before
and made a lot of progress and yesterday
we were exhausted i was exhausted he was
exhausted
and everything looked terrifying to me
because i was tired and i couldn't my
legs weren't
popping i couldn't do the things i was
doing and stuff that i've been doing the
day before i was like oh my god this is
so scary i don't want to do this
and i literally had been doing it the
day before like without even thinking
about it not even like worried
and yesterday i was terrified i was
laughing at myself i was like this is
amazing
that like perception can radically shift
from day to day
um but that's the challenge skills sweet
spot it's a movable
you know it's a movable feast that's my
favorite
trigger how concerned are you that
a lot of knowledge workers and people
that are contributing at the moment and
want to be inflow
are in an environment with always on
communication and
open plan workspaces or slack messaging
channels and stuff like that
which is directory yeah
like that there's there that um
we've created a world that is
significantly like
anti-flow well you've said the precursor
to flow is focus
and focus is incredibly scarce open
office plans
are very problematic um endless
communication can be very problematic
um you know i people always say what's
the one flow trigger i could like what
should i start with and i always say the
best thing
what our what our research has shown is
start your day with 90 minutes of
uninterrupted concentration
devoted to your hardest task or start
your work session
you should start your work session in
accordance with your circadian rhythms
i'm an extreme luck four am my wife's a
night out four pm is when she starts to
wake up and she's not really awake till
nine pm
right so work if you can work in
conjunction with your your basic
biorhythms really great um
fantastic and try to block
90 minutes of unerrupted concentration
at the front end of that period now
90 minutes is very particular the human
brain evolved to focus in 90 minute
cycles the same way we've got like a 90
minute rem cycle that you probably heard
about
we've got a 90-minute waking cycle where
we're awake and we're focused and we're
alert
montessori education uh is very high
flow education when they go to
going to measure flow in educational
environments montessori education and
wall of
schools go off the charts why is that
well one of the main reasons is they
divide the workday into 90 minute blocks
of uninterrupted concentration
self-directed learning for 90-minute
blocks and they get tremendous results
because the human brain is biologically
hardwired for 90 minutes we're good at
it so it doesn't take
a [ __ ] ton of training to learn how to
focus for that period of time
once you turn everything else off and
after
you know as i said we train about a
thousand people a month i've been i've
probably
my staff figured out i have no idea this
is right but let's let's just even say
it's in the ballpark of right
between the people i've spoken to and
trained i've trained over a quarter
million people
it's a lot of people so it's a big data
set
um and the thing that matters seems to
make the biggest difference for most
people is
90 minute block about an hour of
concentration and we talked about the
challenge skills balance
how do you approach the task that you're
going to do in that 90-minute block
you push that task to the edge of your
abilities
so when i'm writing in the morning i'll
give you a really simple example so this
is an atmospheric
i've got 90 minutes when i start writing
a book
i try to write 500 words a day why 500
because 350 i can do easily that's not a
problem
but 500 words means i've got one id and
now i've got to connect it to the next
and i got to write a transition
and transitions as anybody who's ever
written a book will tell you
are the [ __ ] right they're hard and
so 500 words it's i'm stretching myself
i'm not snapping
when it's the middle of a book and i
sort of know a little bit more of what
i'm doing and where i'm going it's 750
words at the end of a book it's a
thousand and twelve hundred
so it moves every day but i've got my
90-minute block
and i know what i'm gonna do with it
because it's based on the challenge
skills
you know balance you can apply that to
anything in your life and those are like
people are always like well where do i
start where do i start where do i start
that's where you start i think and if
your nervous system is running hot
add in daily mindfulness gratitude and
you know inspiration and yes i let me
say the final thing that i have to say
now
which is the caveat which is like i get
that everything i'm talking about
is very simple and very straightforward
i like to point out that i like
i don't like whiz-bang technologies and
i don't like substances
um primarily because i want something
that works every time in every
situation there are a lot of crisis
situations peak performance situations
where there's no time to reach for a
substance or a
you know or a technology or whatever but
that said that's the good news the bad
news is
nothing i talk about if you talk about
it in a bar on friday night it's going
to get you laid
like it won't get you it's not sexy it's
not sex
dude i am i got i got a 90 minute block
of under
concentration and i'm pushing on the
tail and skills balance
you want to come home with me
you considered doing like the flow
dating collective i know right
no but the best part is uh this is even
funnier
so art impossible comes out right right
the new book comes out
and i think i'm on a podcast
very early on very early like before the
books even out
and i say and i don't even know what
podcast mom i must be on
a dating podcast that i don't even know
how it got on but i say look i think the
first impossible that
most people sort of go after in their
life is remember being like 11
12 13 years old and like wanting your
first kiss
or your first girlfriend or boyfriend or
a relationship and it was a total
impossible
like you had no i 12 years old i would
have given you my arm or at least a
finger right for that information um
it was such an impulse when i was like
this is i think the first like people
hear about the art impossible they're
like no way man i'm not interested i
don't
well you do it all the time right and
here's the first
example in your life and i gave that
example so
why this is funny and why i'm telling
you is that the first
time art impossible hit a bunch of like
top amazon bestseller lists
um early on the first one it hit was
mating and i like i was like how the
hell did my book become number one i was
number one in
mating i was like well what the hell is
mating like what does that even mean i
was
relationships with a different category
mate seeking that was it was mate
seeking
i was like relationships is his own
category what could pot what is meat
seeking
and who at amazon was smoking what
when they come up with mate-seeking like
i don't like is where the
anthropologist getting stoned like what
happened there
i don't get it so funny man yeah it's so
bizarre when you see where you
where your work ends up one thing that
i've heard you talk about before
which i'm gonna be remiss if i don't
bring it up is about the importance of
keeping
our word to ourselves thank you for
bringing that up
i think it's such um
it's such a simple concept
all right so let's back up one step i i
i realize that we're gonna have
arbor impossible is the peak performance
primer there's a bunch of onboarding
stuff that you have to do
but by all said and done at the end of
the book if you're really interested in
peak performance and leveling up your
game
um there's about six things you want to
do every day and about seven things to
do every week
and the six things we've been talking
about some of them mindfulness gratitude
or exercise
a 90 minute block for an intervention
these are things that you anybody can do
the point is that it's about doing them
today doing them tomorrow doing the net
reliable repeatable that's what really
matters because peak performance
really does its best work like compound
interest right that's where you really
get the big benefits
put simply peak performance is a
checklist
and what i always tell people is when i
put something on a checklist
like when i at the end of every day i
make up a checklist for what i'm doing
the next day
when i put it on the checklist i'm
making a promise to myself that i'm
doing this tomorrow
right you can
we think a lot we talk a lot about
transparency
not lying honesty keeping our word to
other people and i'm not saying that's
unimportant but i'm saying that is far
less important
than keeping your word to yourself the
most important thing
is if you say it out loud if you say
you're gonna do it
it's a promise it's you've said it to
the world you put it into the world
now you do it if it goes on the list now
you do it it's not
debatable and if it stops being
debatable
so much uh it just gets so much easier i
oh
i like to tell my friend uh i was it's
funny i was telling my editor my i'm
lucky enough that my editor is my best
friend and we've worked together for 25
years
and uh we worked together all the time
and he we were talking the other day and
he said you said something to me once
about this very topic he said that
really stuck with me
and okay what did i say oops um he said
he said it's funny he said when you
write the list
um you're one person and when you're
acting out the checklist you're somebody
else and you said to me like
i just worked for the boss the boss is
the guy who wrote the list
you know i'm just showing up today and
i'm working for the boss
the boss says this is the list that's
the list that's the boss i'm work
because
you don't want to work for present tense
self present tense self is like
[ __ ] it man where's the bourbon right
like
hookers and cocaine man you know
past tense self is like no man if you
really want to get the most out of
tomorrow you're going to go to the gym
in the morning
you're going to start your day with 90
right like you don't want to work
for present tense self unless you have
some kind of like
amazing level of like willpower kung fu
you think about it like you you work for
past tense self the person who made the
checklist and you keep your word to
yourself
and it is it's a muscle
but if you get good at it it's amazing
i'll tell you
i will say here's the difficulty with it
and it's not a personal difficulty it's
a i
say this to everybody i work with and
everybody comes into my company
every day i work with and i say look i
am not
normal in one particular way which is
everything i if i say it out loud i'm
gonna do it it's a promise
and i mean it but if you say it out loud
to me
i think it's a promise and you're gonna
do it no matter what
so if you work with me you have to
understand that if you say it out loud
and you don't do it
we're not going to work together anymore
like that to me is you just broke a
promise and i can't trust you
and we're done um unless you know we
talk about it along the way you tell me
why you're breaking this problem you
know what i mean that kind of thing
um and i find it can be that it's so
it's a difficult it's it's funny it's
the
best peak performance muscle i can think
of and it's great to develop
but if you do develop it the real world
sometimes gets pretty weird because most
people
don't play that way dude i absolutely
love i'm just working for the boss
that is fantastic because but the other
thing about it that's really good about
it is
you're taking yourself and putting
yourself in the third it gives you a
little bit of
emotional remove and there's space there
right you can
you can work with it a little bit and
it's
yeah i'm just so i that's that's he's
got me i'm gonna now be talking about it
i'm just working for the boss cause
he liked it you liked it so i love it
i love it when so many things come
together like that you're totally
correct you've got the
um the third party perspective in there
which is actually distancing you from
stuff what you've done is you've
separated
out the planning and the execution self
which is allowing you to go from system
to
system one to system two thinking and
daniel kahneman speak and you've got
oh i've got my more abstract goals i can
actually make my planning and then when
you get into it it allows you to get
into flow
i imagine long-term planning in flow
probably sucks quite a bit so it's
interesting
so it's interesting it's that's not true
but it's really complicated why
um long-term so a couple of things one
why does time pass so strangely flow
let's start there because this is going
to make sense
time is a calculation performed all over
the prefrontal cortex
parts of it start to shut down for these
efficiency exchanges right the brain
needs more energy it says okay we're
going to shut down non-critical
structures
liberate some energy that's why the
prefrontal cortex turns off
time is a network effect like any
network the nodes go down brain can't
separate paths from present from future
so we're crushed into this thing called
the deep now
so what is problem in
flow couple things are really amazing so
first of all long term planning is great
because you can see
farther into the future normally human
time horizons are about six months
literally like we evolved in an era
where like winter is coming oh [ __ ] i
gotta find a cave
that we gotta follow the harvest like
that sort of stuff
um there was work by uh janet mcdonald
that said that most people have
a 10-year time horizon and that's like
the hard and fast block
and in fact uh when we one of my
organizations plan at home
we help big companies uh basically
become very very environmentally
friendly at a really deep level
and we do it by retrocrasting we say
okay
what is the world you want to live in in
2035 and if that's the case what has to
happen in 2033
31 right and because you because of
those time horizons so in
flow we don't have those time horizons
you can see
much farther in the future in fact then
there's a bunch of other reasons so
that's
really up here's the problem in flow you
can like a
composer will have a sympathy it'll pop
into his head he'll see it in flow and
he'll think
oh dude it's gonna take me like two
weeks i'll just get back i'll i'll write
it you know what i mean
it's all fine or i'll have a book id and
i'll be like oh i'll write this thing in
two months i got this
and then you like drop out of flow when
time is no longer depressed and you're
like
holy crap that's a 15-year project right
like what am i talking about
and that's really demotivating for a lot
of people like it's funny but it's
really demotivating
so long-term planning in terms of
you want to be cautious about like risk
assessments and things like that so like
people go to burning man they get into
flow they decide oh them now is so much
more important than than
i'm gonna cheat on my wife because i'm
having this sacred experience
right like that's the kind of stuff
where long-term planning goes away
right like that those kinds of
situations
yeah but there's a certain kind of like
entrepreneurial or crea artistic
long-term planning where like
every one of my books have appeared to
me in one person or another in flow
and then i've steered towards that it
takes a very long
time right so the flow is sort of it's
great for the intuition the inspiration
but i always tell people i'm like you
have to understand there's an order to
the process
inspiration research
publication communication meaning
have your inspiration do your research
publish it in some way meaning take it
public and let other people
smart people bang on your idea and tell
you if you're right or you're wrong
and then stand up on a stage to write a
book and say okay here's the facts
too many people have the inspiration and
then write the book and then like or
start talking about it
you know what i mean i'm like you just
came back from a flow experience and
you're now going to tell me about god
the universe and ever i mean like
what like get me to the library
it's so funny that flow is is kind of
like a like a mental disorder within
particular domains it's almost like a
um a misappropriation of your mental
faculties
it it's fantastic for a lot of stuff
but if there's there's places where it
gets a little wonky and
i mean and it just just didn't go to a
little bit of wonky i mean of course
it's
optimal performance so you would expect
when optimal performance goes wonky
it's gonna go does wonky fast and hard
right yeah it's gonna go fast
and hard and and it's true i mean it's
funny because
you know in stealing fire we write about
jerusalem syndrome
so jerusalem syndrome is what happens
when people go to jerusalem and there's
so so complexity which is
overwhelming when the brain encounters
information there's too much information
to process
but the conscious mind has to sort of
kick it over you have an awe experience
so that's often geological time right
you stand in the grand canyon you you
think
you look or look at the night sky and
you're looking back in time those kinds
of experiences will people go to
jerusalem
and they have historically based aw
experiences
and they often come down with messiah
complexes
they think they're jesus or moses or
abraham
it's called jerusalem syndrome and it's
a flow it's a flow
triggered altered mental illness time is
compressed
ego is huge right all this history
it's literally like we write about it's
a known it's like a known
psychological disorder really routine
people show up
in you know at the hospitals in
jerusalem all the time by the way it's
not just jerusalem
so
the grateful dead used to have a guy
on staff who looked like jerry and he
would walk around
all the people who would go to dead
concerts and take acid
and decide that they were jerry or
decide they had to talk to jerry
and jerry only jerry could understand
them so they got a guy who looked like
fairy would go around rock med where
they took all the people having bad
trips
and say i'm jerry what do you what what
do you mean i was in that
damn camp one day um i never went to see
the dead
uh of somebody uh i went to a concert
dylan and a bunch of people were playing
one of the guys i was with that didn't
even know him
overdosed on acid tried to take his
clothes off and he's running around the
oakland coliseum
we're chasing him the cops are chasing
us
rock bed is chasing the cops right all
to get the naked guy
who thinks he's jerry and so like i'm
not even on drugs right i'm just like i
don't who is this guy
what's wrong with it i get taken to the
tent in the basement and i'm just
sitting down there like
can i please go upstairs and watch the
damn show i don't even like the dead
that much but like i want to see dylan
and this guy looks like jerry comes up
to me puts his hand on me he's like
are you okay i'm jerry is there
something you need to tell me i was like
you're not [ __ ] jerry
go away surrogate surrogate jerry
gary i was like where's my goddamn
concert get me out of acid lockup this
is no good
[ __ ] that's so funny man yeah the um
the grateful dead i watch i listen to a
podcast series there's an awesome
podcast series about the grateful dead
uh and about all of the history and the
different stuff that they got themselves
into
was so good as a final thing
go ahead please go ahead yours
as a final suggestion
let's say that there's somebody who's
listening who doesn't necessarily have
that
that hobby or that passion that allows
them to stretch their skills and
do this is there a easy
to complete drop into flow practice that
people can do tomorrow
well everybody has a primary flow
activity
this whatever that's that's that's
whatever you did from the time you were
like a little kid to now
that is deeply absorbed for some people
it's reading or walking in nature
or dancing to hip-hop or dancing salsa
or skiing or you know for me it's skiing
everyone's got their own thing and
what's interesting is as we become
adults
these are the very things we stop doing
right like
put away childish things we're
responsible now i'm not going to surf
anymore i'm not going to skate anymore
i'm not going to play my guitar
and from a performance perspective
that's a disaster and there's three
reasons why
one flow is essentially a focusing skill
so the more flow you get the more flow
you get if i go skiing on monday and
drop it into flow and then i go to work
tuesday or wednesday or thursday you'll
get more flow
because you're training the brain out of
focus two as we move into flow
uh all the stress hormones get pushed
out of our system there's a global
release of nitric oxide it's a gases
signaling molecules everywhere in the
body it pushes stress hormones out of
our system
resetting the nervous system towards
zero so we talked about
all the problems with anxiety for
performance flow automatically flushes
that stuff out of your system
also uh massive heightening of
creativity
and productivity and flow and there's
research that shows definitely on the
creativity productivity as a maybe but
the creativity hidden
creativity will outlast a flow state by
a day maybe two
and the thing same thing may be true for
uh productivity
um the creativity research was done by
uh theresa mobley at harvard
um and uh productivity we've been
working on
um at the flow research collective so
the
you get productivity and creativity
that's gonna last outlast your flow
state
you've got you're resetting your nervous
system and you're training the brain
in the flow um so
we teach people to sort of try to double
down if you can
four hours a week devoted to your
primary flow activity
spread out sort of however you want
seams three to four hours seems to
sort of be enough to start moving the
needle
and um
the interesting thing is anything that
moves the needle a little bit that
starts to be really absorptive
once you know what flows triggers are
you just start layering those triggers
in
and you can deepen and lengthen the flow
state
so are impossible breaks down the flow
triggers or you know
stevencottler.com or
flowresearchcollective.com there's
a whole bunch of free stuff you don't
even have to you know buy the book
there's a bunch of free stuff that will
kind of break those things down for you
um and how to use them and you know
primary flow activity and then start
practicing sort of with the flow
triggers
inside of the thing that you know is
already
and then start transferring other to
other parts of your life that's where i
start and i you know if you don't have
four hours a week for
primary flow activity or 90 minutes a
day for uninterrupted concentration
start by starting 10 minutes and five
minutes right like don't it doesn't
there it is not just because you don't
have that amount of time now the good
news about flow
massive heightener of productivity you
get way more done so you're going to end
up
getting time back right that we always
say in peak performance there are places
in people you have to go slow to go fast
this is one of those
dude awesome today's been so
so good the art of impossible a peak
performance primer will be linked in the
show notes below on amazon along with
everything that you've gone through
today and whatever else i can find
if people want is it the passion recipe
oh yeah that's where that yeah by the
way if you are interested in more
passion
go to thepassionrecipe.com it's a
curiosity is designed we built into
passion
passion
is designed to be built into purpose
none of them are supposed to be super
mystical
it's actually a fairly easy thing to do
so if you don't know what you're
passionate about
you do know what you might be curious
about am i curious i mean like you'd
like to
go read a book or two and attend a
lecture or watch a movie or a
documentary i mean i don't mean
you're burning curiosity i mean you're
just like i'd like to learn about this
thing
if you can find a single thing that is
at the intersection of three or four or
five year curiosities and you start to
work there
and learn there that's the seed kernel
of passion and if you want to learn how
to do this more formally
passion recipe.com like flowblocker.com
if that's uh we built that was another
one where like i just got
sick of talking about it so i was like
no let's just build it so i can send
people there because i'm sick of talking
about it
i love it stephen dude thank you so much
for today
it's my pleasure thank you for having me
[Music]